[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis très heureux
d'être ici et de me retrouver dans dans
un amphi une nouvelle fois pour pour
partager ma discipline
vous verrez tout à l'heure pourquoi une
nouvelle fois je vais commencer par vous
familiariser un peu avec cet univers qu
peut-être ou maîtrisez pas tous le kick
boxing et la boxe thaï donc le kick
boxing et la boxe thaï ce sont des boxe
pieds poings
donc on a droit de se servir des dépôts
des bras des genoux et des jambes
on veut que tu es d'écouté circulaire je
vous passe de trop de mouvement parce
que on n'est pas là pour ça et donc ce
sont des combats en fait s'articule avec
cinq rounds de trois minutes et des
récupérations qui vont de une à deux
minutes suivant les pays et les
compétitions et en fait
la boxe est pour moi miraculeuse
puisqu'elle m'a permis de me faire des
choses extraordinaires par les valeurs
qu'elle qu'elle véhicule et qu'elle nous
enseigne et c'est pour moi bien que je
suis pas encore seniors mais je pense
que l'expérience du ring est une
expérience de vie accéléré et c'est ce
que je vais aujourd'hui vous vous
partagez en synchro en première ronde
j'aimerais qu'on
conte laborde comme on aborde sur le
ring finalement puisque quand j'arrive
sur le ring avant même que le la
sonnerie du gong retentissent on est là
les deux adversaires on s'observe on se
regarde on s'analyse on essaye de se
comprendre avant même de se toucher
j'entends par là ce boxer et à partir de
là tous les schémas qu'on avait étudié à
l'entraînement ressurgissent puis bien
sûr il faut pas rester dans cette phase
d'observation et et de passivité puisque
bien entendu il faut commencer par oser
et crée deux du mouvement
c'est cela que c'est comme cela qu'on
peut créer une émotion et créer quelque
chose de de positif dans le combat donc
on démarre toujours en se regardant et
ont créé le contact comme on dit on
prend la température on va jauger son
adversaire comment il réagit et dans la
vie c'est c'est un peu pareil puisque
finalement quand quand j'avais 14 ans je
me suis intéressé aux sports de combat
donc je me suis intéressé de manière
passive à la maison en gardant sur
youtube ou bien des films de rocky par
exemple et il ya eu un élément
déclenchant donc ce petit diable à cette
prise de contact qui a été de me rendre
dans une salle pour découvrir et
apprendre ce sport tout comme un enfant
va apprendre à marcher
non pas que en regardant ses parents
marché mais en essayant de le faire lui
aussi pour le round 2 j'aimerais vous
partager la valeur la plus emblématique
de ma discipline qui est celle de
l'engagement
puisque quand tu es sur le ring tu dois
faire face à trois adversaires et donc
tu ne peux pas faire demi tour
c'est d'ailleurs sanctionné par par
l'arbitré tu dois faire face le regarde
le rester face à luynes pas et ne pas
faire cet engagement est dans la vie de
tous les jours c'est un peu pareil
puisque quand tu rencontres des
difficultés tu dois apprendre à leur
faire face et généralement quand tu
tourne le dos à ses difficultés elle te
revienne dans la figure beaucoup plus
forts qu'eux
que la première fois l'abnégation
j'y viens c'est vraiment la valeur que
qu'on développe en tant qu'athlète de
haut niveau puisque on est obligé de
d'être déterminé au cours de ces 5
grandes puisque rien n'est jamais fini
dans un combat vous savez en boxe on a
cinq rondes on peut perdre un combat
pendant les cinq rondes et le gagner
dans les quelques dernières secondes du
match c'est tout la magie de ce sport
puisque puisque le cas au pardon peut
arriver et cette expérience je vais
d'ailleurs je n'ai d'ailleurs vécu
puisque deux fois dans ma carrière
la première fois sur un titre de
champion de france c'est la deuxième
fois en italie sur un titre de champion
d'europe
g je n'étais pas dedans ça arrive
j'étais ailleurs ce soir là et je perds
le combat jusqu'aux dernières minutes
et aux dernières minutes l'adversaire
qui est complètement déclaré gagnant
dans sa tête puisque finalement ils
gagnent tous les rondes va commencer à
apprendre un peu la confiance et à faire
des choses qui devraient pas faire et
c'est à ce moment précis que là une
opportunité s'ouvre pour moi et que je
peux remporter le combattant alors que
qui n'était pas gagné d'avancé et je
pense que c'est cette valeur
d'abnégation elle est valable pour pour
n'importe quel univers puisque tant
qu'on se continuer à se battre et aller
de l'avant
eh bien eh bien on peut arriver à ses
fins la journée près une mémé j'étais
bienvenue savoir encaisser avant de
donner et oui donc c'est vrai que la
boxe aujourd'hui elle est à la mode on
la pratique de plus en plus mais il faut
bien la comprendre apprendra à donner
des coups c'est quelque chose qu'on
pourrait faire ensemble ça prend
quelques minutes voire un peu plus ses c
à d
des mouvements de bras des mouvements de
jambes des déplacements etc
seulement apprendre à boxer c'est
beaucoup plus que à prendre des coups
c'est apprendre à se défendre et
apprendre à se défendre c'est savoir
toucher sans être touché c'est comme moi
me mohamed ali disait
touché comme une abeille piquer comme
une abeille et voler comme un papillon
et cette phrase là a tout son sens pour
moi puisque la boxe on la voit on a vu
le gars il souvent à deux individus à
deux combattants qui qui se cognent
dessus mais c'est toujours le plus
intelligent qui gagne et non pas le plus
fort et donc je voulais vous parler du
déplacement puisque quand on est sur le
ring
on se déplace on pivote et c est lorsque
je suis enfermée enfin mon déplacement
va me permettre de deux cadres et mon
adversaire tout comme je vais recadrer
ce que je recherche à faire dans dans ma
vie et quand je suis dos aux cordes bien
sûr ma seule issue si je veux continuer
le combat c'est de sortir de cet axe en
pivotant et j'ai l'image du basketteur
qui m'a beaucoup marqué pourquoi le
basketteur puisque un basketteur quand
il reçoit un ballon et qui dribble et
qu'il s'arrête il a le droit de pivoter
de 90 degrés avant de faire une passe et
et dans la vie des fois on s'entête dans
une à vouloir faire quelque chose qui
est pas possible
et il suffit d fois de bouger le prisme
de quelques degrés pour pour y arriver
il ya quelques années je suis rentré à à
dauphine en licence réservé aux sportifs
de haut niveau et c'était donc la
création de cette promotion et à l'issue
de cette promotion
on voulait tous restés à dauphine
seulement on nous a dit c'est pas
possible parce que vous n'avez pas le
niveau vous êtes des sportifs de haut
niveau vous n'avez pas fait la même
licence
c'est bien on est tous tout le monde a
décidé de partir et j'étais profondément
attaché à cette fac et je me suis dis
franchement j'ai envie de rester
donc j'ai fait comme le basketteur je me
suis dit pourquoi ne pas pu voter et se
dire allons faire une licence générale
pour ensuite embrayé sur un master je
n'étais pas un an près et c'est ce que
j'ai fait ce qui m'a permis de d'obtenir
un master plus tard tout ça pour
expliquer que cet art du déplacement
il est valable dans n'importe quel
domaine je pense qu'à partir du moment
où on arrive à avoir une vision
périphérique
on avance plus loin lagarde
je voulais vous en parler puisque c'est
un peu une figure aussi emblématique de
l'as de la boxe là je me suis bien
protégé d'ailleurs
donc ou à ou comment dirais-je
oh c'est la première chose que l'on
apprend à faire finalement on t'apprend
à lever les mains à regarder ton
adversaire et apprendre à bloquer ses
coûts c'est comme au judo où on va
t'apprendre a chuté avant d'apprendre à
faire chuter l'autre il te faut savoir
freiner dans sa voiture avant de avant
d'apprendre à à passer les vitesses
enfin avec ce quatrième round
j'aimerais vous partagez mon ressenti
sur ce qu'est la réussite et la victoire
de mon expérience
déjà nous sommes dans un sport très
ouvert et très à habitat fin très
subjectif on va dire c'est pas comme
dans un match de foot en boxe ou quand
vous mettez tu mets un but il ya 2 0
tout le monde le voit on est tous
d'accord
en boxe on est jugé par des individus
par des arbitres qui ont tous une
sensibilité différente et qui vont tous
émettre un jugement différent sur le
combat donc ce qui compte vraiment est
ce que c'est le jugement de ces arbitres
ou est-ce que c'est ton propre jugement
sur ta prestation
qu'est-ce qui vaut mieux vaut mieux
gagner un combat parce que les arbitres
tu as compris ce qu'ils attendaient ou
est ce qu'il vaut mieux donner de toi le
meilleur de toi même tes mobiliser
toutes les ressources et être fière de
toi à la fin du combat
sa gelée compris après plusieurs échecs
puisque effectivement quand quand tu
penses trop résultats généralement tu
profites pas du voyage
le voyage est dans le combat et quand tu
n'es pas dans le moment présent
eh ben ça passe pas et plusieurs fois ça
n'est pas passé
mais malheur mais heureusement peut-être
puisque c'est parce que ça n'est pas
passé ces fois là que j'ai réussi à
obtenir mais quittera à l'avenir est
dans ma carrière chaque phase de
transition s'est faite par un échec
mon premier combat je l' ai perdu mon
premier combat pro je l' ai perdu mon
premier championnat de france je l' ai
perdu ma première finale de championnat
du monde je les ai perdus et ça m'a pas
empêché de devenir trois fois champion
du monde parce que à chaque fois j'ai
reconstruit derrière et quand on est
dans la victoire
on n'a pas toujours ce recul pour voir
qu'est ce qui n'a pas été qu'est ce qui
a été
on continue d'avancer et festoyer alors
qu'en cas d'échec on se remet en
question et ses lacs et ses dates qu'on
se construit c'est pour ça qu'on a
tendance à parler d'échec
et moi je préfère qu'on parle de
d'apprendre plutôt que de te parler de
d'un échec
enfin pour le cinquième round
j'aimerais vous parler de cet univers
dans la boxe en fait où on apprend à à
mobiliser différentes ressources c'est
j'entends par là donc on le disait on
est sûr de la boxe pieds poings
il m'est arrivé au cours d'un combat de
me casser la main pendant le combat
ça fait mal mais c'est pas c'est pas ça
qui va nous arrêter tant qu'on peut
continuer et à partir de ce moment là je
vais dans mon dans mon coin je suis
super inquiet angoisses et j'en parle à
mon entraîneur comment je vais faire
j'ai plus de main droite j'ai plus de
main droite et à ce moment là ils me
rappellent mes temps encore une main
gauche a encore une jambe gauche est
encore une jambe droite et donc c'est
vrai que parfois quand on se fait mal
enfin ou quand on a une difficulté on a
tendance à se bloquer sur ce qui nous
arrête ou de penser à tout ce qu'on en a
d'autres à toutes nos ressources
supplémentaires
c'est là où la boxe nous renforce et
nous permet d'aller au-delà de nous
mêmes
contrairement peut-être à des sports
collectifs où on peut s'appuyer sur des
collègues
là on a besoin d'aller puiser dans
d'autres ressources personnelles et ce
qui a été merveilleux dans dans le
malheur de l'univers du kickboxing et et
de la boxe thaï c'est que aujourd'hui la
boxe thaï et le kickboxing sont
relativement peu structurée en france et
nous n'avons pas beaucoup
d'accompagnement pour les sportifs de
haut niveau débutant à savoir un centre
comme lindsay qui nous accueillerait de
manière quotidienne et nous encadrerait
pour accéder à des performances
sportives
c'est à nos athlètes de nous débrouiller
et de nous manager de gérer notre
carrière comprendre et ses compétences
là chaque boxeur je dis bien chaque
boxeur va savoir les retranscrire dans
sa vie personnelle dans son parcours
professionnel
personnellement ça a été dans les études
et c'est comme ça que j'ai pu rentrer à
dauphine et de venir
et obtenir un bac +5 et on a eu tendance
enfin comme ils disent et on m'appelait
l'étudiant boxeur etc
mais en vérité c'est tout l'inversé le
boxeur et qui est devenu étudiant et non
pas le l'étudiant qui est qui est devenu
boxeur c'est grâce à ces valeurs que
j'ai pu faire mes études et même plus
même plus parce que l'un est werner la
boxe donc à ma animée demain à nîmes et
via que je disais le fait qu'on se gère
qu'on apprend à gérer nos carrières m'a
poussée à entreprendre puisque j'ai été
confronté à on va dire non pas des noms
mais je n'ai pas reçu ce que j'attendais
d'eux du milieu voilà je suis dans une
catégorie les 81 kg où il n'y a pas trop
d'opportunités en france et donc j'étais
déçu de ne pas être appelé sur les
belles soirées que je voyais où il y
avait d'autres combattants
du coup ça m'a poussé à le faire moi
même tout simplement et donc en dernière
année de master en entrepreneuriat à
dauphine
plutôt que de faire un stage de fin
d'études je me suis dit et pourquoi pas
mais les ton parcours d'étudiant est ton
parcours d'athlète de haut niveau en
organisant un gala de boxe et en
réfléchissant je me suis dit où je
pourrai le faire
et l'idée m'est venue de le faire à
dauphine dans l'amphi puisqu'ils ont un
amphi qui fait à peu près 1200 personnes
quelque chose comme ça un peu plus grand
qu ici c'est pour ça que je disais mon
retour dans l'amphi pour de la boxe au
début et donc j'ai décidé d'organiser ce
ce gala de boxe dans dans l'amphi et j'y
ai disputé un championnat du monde donc
le 27 novembre dernier
et tout ça pour dire que cette cet
élément de ma vie n'a été possible que
parce que j'ai reçu des noms et parce
que je n'ai pas eu ce que j'attendais
donc les noms nous forme
enfin pour conclure on parlait de
miracle ou in the common et je pense que
les potentiels sont extraordinaires chez
chacun de nous et ce qui mène à un mètre
des fois en lumière quelqu'un plus qu'un
autre je pense notamment à tous ces
hommes de l'ombre qui sont des gens de
mon équipe qui participa à ma
performance et qui font que que j'en
suis arrivée là
et donc je leur fais un petit clin
d'oeil dans cette conclusion
puisque sans eux je ne serais d'ailleurs
pas là aujourd'hui et je vais donc finir
sur une métaphore pour le sportif de
haut niveau où mon préparateur physique
serait un peu le moteur d'un du véhicule
et mon entraîneur le levier de vitesse
et donc sans eux je pourrais pas passer
à la vitesse supérieure merci à vous
merci à vous
[Musique]